Richmond, Virginia a success story of the
booming U.S. economy under Trump.
Long gone are the days that big tobacco was
synonymous for Richmonds economic prowess.
The economic strength of the states capital
is in banking, finance and bio-technology
now.
But Richmonds success is in stark contrast
to other parts of Virginia
This is Roanoke, south-west of Richmond in
the Blue Ridge Mountains of the Appalachian
region.
The old railroad town and transportation hub
is home for 300 thousand residents.
Meet Dwayne Yancey, editorial page editor
at The Roanoke Times.
He spent decades reporting on the regions
economic woes.
The number 1 industry here is healthcare now.
The big employer used to be the Railroad,
now its a hospital chain.
The further west you go
the less fortunate the economy will be.
Welcome to Bristol, Virginia - the birthplace
of Country Music.
Literally!
17 thousand residents live on the Virginia
side of town.
26 thousand more in the part that is in Tennessee.
The state line goes right through town and
the middle of Bristols Stage Street.
City manager Randall Eads, just about a year
in the job - is taking us on a city tour in
his golf cart
Bristol has a poverty rate of 23.6 %.
The town just lost another major employer.
A total of 470 people will soon be out of
a job.
What was once the local go-to shopping mall
- is no more.
Thats reality in Bristol - despite Trumponomics,
record job growth and tax reform.
The Economy is more complex thanjust one party
being in control or one President being in
control.
People will say that Mr. Trump is the one
who made the economy boom right now, others
will say it
was because of President Obama.
I dont think either one can necessarily take
credit.
There is hope.
A Chinese company bought American Merchant
and will start textile production in Bristol
soon.
Thats few hundred new jobs, desperately needed.
A local private investor group wants to invest.
They want to build a casino-resort here.
That is thinking big and outside the box,
says city manager Randy.
And that is a must for Bristol in this positive
economic climate, because, You know worst
case scenario is, we have a situation where
the national economy takes a dip.
We go into
a recession or depression.
Bristol will feel the brunt of that at some
point.
And when that happens, when we continue to
loose
business, if people fail to spend, then Bristol
will have a true headache on its hands.
Despite the current strong national economy
people here need more investors and businesses
betting on Bristol.